I am sitting with caral Drogo no tell me
everything what was it like I mean oh my
God Cal Drogo it's a decade ago it's
been a while it's been it's ever present
in all of our
minds um and I I don't know who I was
more excited by you or kisi and then
when the two of you came together I was
like well this is everything I've ever
lived for right here in front of me was
was that fun yeah she's amazing I mean
the whole show is amazing yeah it was a
wonderful time in my life and you're
very big on loin cloths you know you
wear one in real life and then you're
wearing like a suede line you you like
to be in loin cloths which we all like
too I'm not a big fan of clothes yeah
like we didn't Hawai aren't you know we
didn't wear too much so that's a good
thing
yeah I run hot you do I do I I'm I'm a
I'm a yeah I'm a
furnace